you get to pull a sword from a stone I
assume that's a part of so weights a big
bother I mean were you just practicing
that scene in your house and asleep you
know I had a giant stone fortune and
yeah you know we drove the sword into it
and that was basically my main
preparation for film did you keep the
sword though you know what I didn't and
I was promised a sword and I just
realized when there was reference to a
sword being here today potentially that
I thought oh that's convenient
it's probably my sword and so I might
have to take it because no I don't have
a sword and I was promised one you
should go steal it
yeah that would normally be what I would
do there's still anything else I don't
think I did
hey this is the first job I've ever done
where I didn't steal some yeah I stole
so much for something I'm gonna me tell
you why did she stole my cut I stole the
bike I stole a bike
yeah stole the bike oh yeah it's in my
garage I don't know it was like one of
those weird things that like a kid does
because I stole it and then have never
used it what about the Sons of Anarchy
prequel things is that happening are you
gonna be part of that at all I don't I
do believe it is happening but I don't
think I'm a part of it
because I wasn't born when that was
happen it seems like way but I believe
it's sort of like an origin of
motorcycle culture in America so 50 60s
so that's what I believe but again I'm
just really like
when he finds at all
you